بعد اقل من شهر على انفجار اصفهان الذي
وقع في منشاه عسكريه ايرانيه انفجار اخر
غربي العاصمه ونيران المضادات الجويه
تتصدى في مدينه كرنج
الانفجار ناجم عن هجوم بواسطه مسيره
استهدفت سياره بالقرب من حديقه عظيميه في
مدينه كرنج
اترجيحات قالت ان السياره كان يستخدمها
حامد عبد الله قائد الوحده 400 اهم وحده
في فيلق القدس وهي الوحده المسؤوله عن دعم
الميليشيات المواليه لايران ماليا وعسكريا
وفق مصادر مطلعه اكدت مقتل شخصين بعد توجه
السيارات اسعاف الى موقع الانفجار اما
طهران فقالت ان اطلاق النار ناتج عن
مناوره لقوات الباسج الامر عينه سبق
لايران ان اعلنته بعد هجمات وتفجيرات
سابقه مماثله لتتراجع بعد فتره وتؤكد وقوع
ا الانفجار مدينه كراج مليئه بمواقع
وانفاق عسكريه تحت الارض كما توجد فيها
عده مواقع اتصالات ورضارات مركز القياده
للدفاع الايراني والسكونات تابعه للحرس
الثوري